the stunts we see in film can be so
dangerous and complex
they only get one chance to get it right
how did these crews fare
we're checking out how tom holland's
spider-man sword millie bobby brown
doing highly complex stunts in a corset
and the performers who literally lit up
the screen on fire and game of thrones
let's check out all these stunts behind
the scenes and a journalist goes what's
wrong with you
and i said well i do all of my own
stunts
just like pretty much everyone else
we're huge tom holland fans
and he gives us even more reason to love
him when we see him checking his stunts
behind the scenes
check out what it actually looks like
when he surprisingly hops out of the top
of a bus
by the way after seeing this behind the
scenes footage
we can definitely understand why zendaya
wouldn't have had to act out those
screams
before he did spider-man far from home
he amazed us with his stunts in
spider-man homecoming
many of holland's stunts were actually
done in the studio while wearing a
motion capture suit
this was probably for the best since all
of these stunts were so intense
he performed these amazing feats and
then that footage was incorporated into
the scenes that we see in the film
check out how cool these acrobatic
stunts look in a studio with mats
oh remember when he was vertically
climbing this great in reality
it was a bit more horizontal
millie bobby brown has done it again
going behind the scenes
is pretty surprising not because it
looks so different from the movie but
because it looks so
similar as we can see here her intense
boxing style fights with helena bonham
carter is
anything but fake brown is actually a
big fan of boxing and has been since she
was young
judging from what we can see here that's
not a surprise at all
let's also remember the fact that both
performers faced the added danger
element of wearing a corset and period
shoes which could have completely thrown
either of them off while shooting
oh and how can we forget about brown's
head being plunged into this bucket of
water
was it real yes it very much was
keeps flashing i was like okay i'm
splashing i was like literally felt like
i was a shamu show
so we're pretty sure that we can all
agree jennifer lawrence is a total boss
in the hunger games
not only is she an incredibly skilled
fighter she does it all with a bow and
arrow in tow ready to take out
anyone who gets in her way just look how
fast she moves with it
that takes some serious skill boss and
arrows weren't the only weapons on set
though
these terrifying axes totally raised the
bar
oh and this insane tree climb yeah she
did get a bit of help with wires to pull
that one off
of course we can't forget this giant
spinning rock
in reality it was just that
a giant spinning rock we can't even
imagine how nauseating this take must
have been to shoot
yeah a bit average bit blur
first we're gonna focus on the intense
battle of winterfell scene from the
third episode of the final season
just look at how many people there are
to coordinate
that itself is a huge feat it wasn't
just people though
the team had this whole crew of
unpredictable horses for cast mates as
well
as if what we've seen wasn't intense
enough let's check out these performers
on fire
literally on fire
while you might think this is cgi it is
100
the real intense fiery deal the
performers were wearing special fire
resistant fabrics
and are coated in a kind of gel that
holds the flame but keeps the actor safe
we burn more people than anybody else
basically
have you ever wondered how films
accomplish epic car flips while somehow
filming the actors faces pretty
perfectly
we are going behind the scenes with
black panther to give us a bit of a clue
this mechanism is unreal black panther
also had some huge battle scenes that
included loads of people but
not only that they were also wielding
loads of dangerous weapons like the
swords we can see here
and how can we forget this
weapon-wielding water battle
talk about making a splash
loads of the battles in this marvel
movie have long complicated hand-to-hand
combat sequences
while it doesn't look as risky as say a
sword fight
these scenes require a ton of practice
to perform safely
it wouldn't be the mcu without some
flying too thank goodness for wires and
jerkbasts to make captain america sore
the behind-the-scenes peak that probably
surprised us the most was seeing
this stunt happening without any
appearance of a harness or
wires this is definitely next level
stunting
then of course there is this casual
giant truck flip
this is seriously intense
as if complicated physical fights
weren't tough enough in captain america
the winter soldier
we had guns and of course the shield
involved
have you ever wondered how exactly they
film car chase scenes
in this case the cars weren't on a road
at all check out how they're immobile
with the green screen so they could add
the cgi in after the fact
get me off the grid
let's be honest the performers and birds
of prey totally slayed
they looked almost effortless as they're
doing insane stunts and tricky battles
let's also not forget that they're doing
all of this in heels and tight pants
yikes now this is a pretty unique stunt
that's right we're talking rollerblading
margot robbie is kind of unbelievable on
those rollerblades
even with the running on the toes
definitely not an easy thing to do
just in case anyone was wondering mulan
behind the scenes is
pretty much the mulan we see on our
screens at home
all of these fierce battles took months
of intensive training in traditional
martial arts and weapons training
check out those swords and bows and
arrows need to run up a wall
the milan team has a solution for that
so is it just us or are these behind
behind-the-scenes stunts still
just as impressive as what we see in the
final cut
it's not every day you see this on a
train
but thanks to wires and jerk vests the
captain marvel team was able to make
this a reality
while we know larson was hooked up to
wires like many of the other marvel
actors are
how exactly did they achieve her
fantastical spinning and soaring
as we can see she had this large
spinning
prong mechanism helping her navigate
through space
you can beat me
we would kind of expect giant truck
flips and car accidents to be done with
cgi
considering how dangerous and expensive
they are to shoot
but when they were filming the dark
knight the team clearly didn't take
any shortcuts for this insane son in
particular
they had only one chance to get the shot
talk about pressure
it was a huge risk but fortunately the
stuntman who was up close and personal
with the scene escaped
unharmed impressively the shot we see in
the final cut is
actually the original continuous take
we cannot get over how cool this beach
battle scene looks
while hippolyta defying gravity might
have been added with cgi
for the most part the scene we saw was
actually real
one of the biggest challenges was
shooting such a large roof all at once
every single person had to be perfectly
in sync to pull this off
all of these horses also had to pull
their weight on set and from what we can
see
they nailed it this motorcycle stunt
totally blew our minds special shout out
to the camera guy who is also casually
riding along
naturally this whole bridge had to be
blocked off to make room to set up the
stunt as safely as they could
just the fact that the ground is wet is
a whole other level of danger
because of the weaving in and out of
these very tight vehicles
took a very skilled rider so what did it
take to help the flash pull off his
lightning speed
this trusty green screen treadmill did
the trick while it might seem
simple he has to run incredibly fast and
doesn't have anything to hold on to
combine that with a restrictive costume
it's a very dangerous situation
yes it's gross the ingenuity of the
teams involved in making the stunt magic
happen is pretty incredible
not to mention all those stunt horses
which stunt did you think was the
riskiest